black bling bling bling oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah hey guys on a be sharp
welcome to Abby's kitchen if I was gonna
eat one thing every day for the rest of
summer it would definitely be popsicles
so that's why I partnered with my
friends at all brands to make really
great high fiber popsicles that I legit
can justify eating all day long these
banana cream pops are loaded with summer
berries have a high fiber all brand
filling and our gift in chocolate
seriously you can skip the ice cream
truck this year guys because these
popsicles are honestly what summers all
about in a food processor I pureed some
plain fat-free Greek yogurt for some
protein and two small ripe bananas for
natural sweetness then I stir in my
chopped strawberries raspberries and
blueberries and I set it aside then in a
small bowl I mix together some Kellogg's
all-bran med cereal some crushed graham
crackers and some honey until it all
comes together I love using all ran in
these pops because not only do they give
you a nice control contrast but they
also give you about half of your fiber
needs in just a third of a cup that's
pretty impressive then I divide about
half the yogurt mixture between six
popsicle molds then add about three
cores of cereal mixture and packing
gradients down with a spoon before
adding two tablespoons of milk to each
mold continue with the remaining yogurt
then sprinkle the last bit of cereal
onto the yogurt insert the ice pop
sticks into them and freeze for at least
four hours ideally overnight but I know
it's really hard to wait now we have
some fun
so before serving I mixed together some
dark chocolate with a little bit of
coconut oil pop the whole thing into the
microwave and I put it in there for
about 30 seconds until it's all melted
down to a smooth
and then we give it a quick little dip
at it instantly hardens into a nice
delicious chocolate shell
see you got your yogurt you got your
berries
we got your high-fiber cereal it's
practically breakfast with chocolate
that's dress missing ever
well guys you can always check out some
more great high-fiber recipes using the
hashtag all brand new in the meantime if
you like what you saw be sure to give me
a thumbs up leave me a comment below
some of your favorite summer times
dessert recipes subscribe to the channel
and I'll see you next time on Abbey's
kitchen
you